KELLY CAYLOR: We need
to be cooking and be
very efficient with
our time as we're
cooking the dinners tonight.
I know you guys have all looked
at your menus and studied them.
FRANCES LODGE: The reason I took
this class is because I hadn't
taken a freshman seminar yet.
And I kind of looked
at the course offerings
and thought, how
could I not apply
for such a cool opportunity?
I came in with no cooking
experience at all.
And I think freshman
year is a good time
to learn such a
basic life skill.
And I thought, like, what was
a better opportunity than now?
So, yeah.
ANGELA WANG: It's
practicing science
when you're cooking--
like, whenever
you have a question, like, he
incorporated the answer into,
like, teaching while
teaching you how to cook.
And whenever they
bring experts, you
don't want to miss anything
that they're saying.
INSTRUCTOR: Yeah.
OK?
You have reserved
juice, if you think
it still needs more cooking.
Follow?
STUDENT: Will you do that?
STUDENTS: --42, 43, 44, 45, 46--
DANIEL SHEPARD: We've
talked a lot about,
like, gastronomy and
the way flavor works.
So, olfactory perception,
retronasal effects of,
like, how you eat food.
So when I eat this bread with
this delicious butter on it--
mmm-- not only is my tongue
tasting these flavors,
but my olfactory glands
are picking up perceptions.
That's going
straight to my brain.
And so we've talked a lot
about that kind of science
and then also about
agricultural sustainability.
[CONVERSATIONS]